We are doing all we can, of course,...
...to meet our needs, to foster our interests,...
...and also to accommodate the will of the wider world.
As I said before, we are an example in the eyes of the world...
...when it comes to an environmental agenda.
Brazil is a wonderful place, magnificent people...
...and because of the vibrant, inclusive democracy...
...and strong electoral institutions,...
...our nations are linked by deeply rooted, shared values...
...that unlocks incredible opportunities for both our nations in my view.
This year, we will be having elections in Brazil...
...and we do wish to have honest, clean,...
...transparent, auditable and reliable elections.